c'est étonnant ce matin ses petites
fleurs blanches sont fermées ce sont des
oxalis alors qu'il hier en milieu
d'après midi elle était complètement
ouverte et celle ci aussi 6,6 et la
petite caméra l'a filmé comme si elle
avait fermé les yeux pendant la nuit
peut-être qu'elles dorment encore que
phénomène s'appelle elle à nu dynastie
ou là il ya des racines grecques là
dessous normal on parle de plantes le
grec permet de décrire précisément le
phénomène et en plus c'est un langage
international pour les botanistes je
vous éclaire ça va vous êtes toujours là
nick de nick ce qui veut dire nuit et
nasty
pour mouvement on parle aussi de
position de sommeil comme si la plante
avait besoin de fermer les paupières
pour s'endormir
c'est pas la seule mais comment ce
mouvement est il possible alors que la
plante ne possède ni muscles me système
nerveux
pour comprendre il faut observer un
pétale de très près encore plus prêt que
ne le font les insectes comme ça ça va
dans l'épaisseur
il est constitué d'un empilement de
cellules chaque cellule se présente sous
la forme d'une petite brique à
l'intérieur de laquelle se trouve un sac
appelé vacquerolles qui contient de
l'eau il y a aussi des sels minéraux du
calcium notamment
c'est le noyau de la cellule qui
renferme le matériel génétique de la
plante quand la nuit tombe
la baisse de luminosité entraîne une
modification de la concentration en
calcium
il y en a davantage dans les cellules
qui se trouve sous le pétale pour
rétablir l'équilibré
ces cellules se gorge d'eau tandis que
celle du dessus se ville et se contracte
ça pousse d'un côté ça tract de l'autre
les pétales se referme
[Musique]
on peut illustrer le phénomène avec un
ballon de baudruche et une feuille de
papier très léger je représente les
cellules qui se trouve sous le pétale en
gonflant les cellules prennent du volume
et le pétale se redresse comme celle ci
[Musique]
alors ça je m'y attendais pas ajoutez à
cela la contraction des cellules qui se
trouve au dessus et qui exerce une
attraction et le pétale se redresse
d'autant plus facilement
je recommence voilà le pétale j'étais
couché s'est redressé dans mon jardin le
phénomène dure environ 10 minutes et
c'est très beau au petit matin celle
inverse les cellules qui se trouve au
dessous ce vide et se contracte celle
qui se trouve au dessus se gorge d'eau
ça pousse au dessus ça tracts en dessous
et la flore s'ouvre et c'est aussi très
beau mais attention les plantes ne font
pas cela pour attirer notre regard et la
fleur héberge les organes sexuels de la
plante les étamines qu'ils portent à
leurs extrémités des petits sacs de
pollen les cellules entre lectrices mal
de la plante et le pistil qui contient
sa base les ovules et les cellules
reproductrices femelles ces plantes ont
besoin des insectes pollinisateurs pour
se reproduire
les abeilles par exemple le jour elles
vont de fleur en fleur pour faire le
plein de nectar et de pollen en passant
d'une fleur à l'autre elle transporte le
pollen de lune sur le pistil de l'autre
et participent ainsi activement à la
reproduction des clous
la nuit quand les insectes se repose la
fleur se referme pour protéger ses
organes reproducteurs du froid et de
l'humidité et faire en sorte qu'au petit
matin les insectes et de quoi se mettre
sous la dent et polliniser
chaque plante à son propre rythme elles
se sont adaptées au fil de l'évolution à
l'activité de leurs pollinisateurs il
existe des plantes par exemple dont la
pollinisation dépendent animaux
nocturnes c'est le cas de certains
analysent sauvages qui sont
essentiellement pollinisées par des
chauve-souris leurs fleurs s'ouvrent
donc la nuit et se referme le jour
carl von linné le célèbre botaniste
suédois du xviiie siècle et est l'auteur
de la première classification des
plantes
depuis elle a bien sûr été revu et
corrigé mais avant c'était vraiment la
jungle carl von linné a même réalisé une
horloge floral lorsqu'il était en guyane
il était capable de deviner leur réelle
en observant l'ouverture des fleurs
quand cette petite fleur jaune s'ouvrent
une mûre titulariat il est aux alentours
de 7 heures quand la nympho izany ka ou
faux nez du phare s'épanouit les 8
heures à 9 heures c'est lily zante qui
ouvre les volets et à 10k bomba
aquatique à elle commence à se fermer
je vais être en retard faut vraiment que
j'y aille à très bientôt avec la petite
caméra
nous aussi nous allons prendre un peu de
vacances du coup jusqu'à la rentrée
nous ne nous retrouverons plus qu'une
fois tous les quinze jours
ce n'est pas tout la prochaine fois le
25 juillet donc la vidéo sera un peu
différente des précédentes
en seulement 3 mois vous avez franchi le
cap des 500 milles abonnés c'est énorme
merci à toutes et à tous pour fêter ça
je prépare une vidéo faq pour répondre à
toutes vos questions sur les capsules
les coulisses des tournages les
prochains monde de jamie également posé
les en commentaire de cette vidéo en
commençant par dit jamie ou sur twitter
en commençant par hashtag dit jamais je
suis impatient de vous lire et de vous
répondre
à très bientôt et passer d'excellentes
vacances